[Music]
up to now legendary's procedure with
regard to the release of projects from
the monsterverse has not always been met
with sympathy from fans which is why
they will be releasing films and series
on several streaming services at the
same time in the future as was announced
recently disney is now also creating its
own series about king kong and the
notorious skull island however there are
not any references to the monster verse
and disney is rather focusing on its
very own story the script was written by
stephanie folsom who worked on projects
including toy story 4 and paper girls
and she is also involved as an executive
producer in addition to her role as a
scriptwriter horror icon james wan and
his company atomic monster are also
among the producers but so far there has
been no mention of the director we
assume that the disney plus king kong
series will be based strongly in the
original film from 1933 however more
details and a release date are not
available yet
with a recent decision by warner
brothers executives to scrap batgirl as
well as scooby-doo a murmur went through
hollywood and the entire world of film
many fear that even more warner projects
will be canceled as those responsible
around ceo david zazloff want to focus
on more blockbuster films and less on
smaller productions like batgirl in the
near future one movie that will
definitely not be dropped is the
upcoming sequel to the batman the
continuation is still in the works and
will certainly be released which is
great news for fans of the first part
director matt reeves is in charge of the
script along with matson tomlin who also
worked on the first movie and is also
the author of the comic book series
batman the imposter since the screenplay
is still in progress we cannot expect
any details regarding the plot of the
film anytime soon but we are still
looking forward to seeing what happens
next and we'll keep you posted
slowly but surely the release of the hbo
series the last of us is approaching
following some information and updates
about the series in the last couple of
months and weeks new footage is now
available in a preview from hbo max you
can see all kinds of series that are
either just getting started or getting a
new season among them is the last of us
which is particularly subject to
critical scrutiny among game players due
to it being an iconic game franchise the
story revolves around joel and ellie in
the starring roles we see the
mandalorian actor pedro pascal as joel
and game of thrones actress bella ramsay
as ellie in the newly released scenes we
get to see the two of them wandering
around in a snowy landscape along with a
few more glimpses of other characters
even though this is still far from being
a trailer many were happy about the
first moving images which definitely
make you want to see more so far the
responsible parties are aiming for a
release date in early 2023 but a more
precise date has yet to be confirmed
the long-awaited sequel to knives out
will soon be coming to the streaming
service netflix for a couple of months
we have known the official title is
glass onion a knives out mystery and now
we already got some first footage among
others we get to see fight club star
edward norton rapper and actress janelle
monae one night in miami actor leslie
odom jr one division actress catherine
hahn and of course lead actor daniel
craig as detective benoit blank
according to the official synopsis the
plot is about a new case that is
supposed to take place on the private
island of billionaire miles brawn while
friends and acquaintances of him are
invited for a visit a great misfortune
happens that only benoit blank himself
can solve by the way the title glass
onion is a tribute by knives out
director ryan johnson to the beatles who
also published a song with this title
glass onion a knives out mystery will
celebrate its world premiere at the
toronto international film festival in
september and it will then be available
for streaming on netflix starting on
december 23rd 2022
with henry cavill helena bonham carter
and millie bobby brown enola holmes from
2020 has a notable cast after mostly
positive reviews netflix is now teasing
the second part via its social media
channels the streaming service has
posted a first look in the form of six
images together with the release date
several of the actors are back along
with the starring trio new cast members
include wonder woman actor david thulas
four lines actor adil akhtar and hannah
dodd who is known from eternals for
example both the director and the
screenwriter remain unchanged from the
previous film in the form of harry
bradbeer and jack thorne meaning that
familiar crew members are relied upon in
terms of content the sequel picks up
where its predecessor left off so we get
to see nola's first steps as an
independent detective as well as her
first case which centers on a missing
girl hopefully as with the first part
the movie will be able to impress
especially with the chemistry between
millie bobby brown and henry cavill who
happen to be siblings in front of the
camera and nola homes 2 will be
available on netflix from november 4th
this week deadline reported on
production related news for the next
planet of the apes movie the blockbuster
which will be directed and scripted by
maze runner director west ball and josh
friedman is currently in the midst of
production and we now know who will play
the main role the talk is of it actor
owen t who will take over the facial
expressions and movements of the new
main character using the tried and true
method of motion capture sadly it is not
quite clear yet in which direction the
new planet of the apes will take that is
whether it will be a sequel or a reboot
we merely know that the new lead actor
and that the script is supposed to have
already been finalized in some way it
will also be related to the original
adaptation of pierre bull's 1968 novel
in contrast to many other installments
of the planet of the apes franchise the
film series was given a halfway decent
reboot in 2011 with rise of the planet
of the apes and as a result many fans
are in favor of a reboot of sorts for
the next planet of the apes movie west
ball for his part revealed on twitter
that caesar played by andy circus will
keep playing a role in the film we are
very excited and look forward to more
information about the new movie
last week said photos from the upcoming
disney plus series percy jackson and the
olympians popped up after filming has
only been running for just under a month
these are the first visual impressions
that have been made public after the
leak disney even followed up and shared
the first official image on it you can
see the starring trio consisting of leah
jeffries walker scobel and ariem
simandre percy jackson creator rick
riordan also recently spoke about the
movie adaptation of his books here
ryerton expressed his satisfaction with
production and even goes so far as to
say that he could not imagine the
protagonists without thinking of these
three actors in addition he is involved
not only as an advisor but also as an
executive producer and thus has a
significant influence on the production
which should delight fans of the book
series so far there is no set release
date for percy jackson and the olympians
but those responsible are hoping for an
early 2024 release
in 2020 ghost of tsushima one of sony's
best games for the past few years was
released on the playstation 4 primarily
the constant references to japanese
cinema and director akira kurosawa as
well as the breathtakingly beautiful
game world made the game created by
developer studio sucker punch
productions sell over 9 million units
within 2 years in its original form the
game in which you play the samurai jin
sakai is produced entirely in japanese
but of course it does feature
corresponding audio output and subtitles
the final movie is supposed to turn out
very similarly at least according to
director chad stahlski the john wick
director recently spoke in an interview
with collider about the way the upcoming
film will be made and it promises to be
extremely authentic due to his
connection to the japanese cult director
kurosawa among other reasons the ghost
of tsushima movie will be released in
japanese with appropriate subtitles
stachelski sees little issue with this
since western audiences are used to
reading subtitles anyway but that's not
all all the actors involved are also
expected to be from japan after all the
mongol invasion of the island of
tsushima which is the main subject of
the game was also a japanese affair sony
is said to be very much behind the idea
so it should only be a short period of
time before shooting starts there is no
exact release date for the movie yet
though given the early stage of
production we should not count on a
release in the next two years
well that was the news for this week if
you need more exciting infos we
recommend our latest original episode
about the upcoming super mario brothers
movie in it we take an in-depth look at
the production the cast and the possible
storyline we hope you enjoy it
[Music]